if you didn't hear the sad news platinum
games Xbox one and PC exclusive
scalebound has been cancelled rumors
circled as to why the game was axed and
director Hideki Kamiya has responded on
Twitter he apologized saying he'd work
extra hard to make sure something like
this doesn't happen again and as for the
rumor about him taking time off for
mental health that's a big fat no
Platinum Games chief executive kenichi
Sato also released a statement saying we
are very disappointed things ended up
this way especially since we know so
many of our fans were looking forward to
this game as much as we were going
forward we will strive to continue
delivering high quality games to you
starting with near automaton March and
including products like grand blue
fantasy project relink and lost order in
the future fortunately Xbox one has more
games in the chamber for 2017 including
crackdown 3 and Halo Wars to keep an eye
on gamespot for the latest on both of
those and more and for all the biggest
Xbox news you're already in the right
place
you